- Mary-Sophie Harvey admet avoir
se trouvait en Hongrie,
aux Championnats du monde
de la Fédération internationale
de natation.
MARY-SOPHIE HARVEY, nageuse
professionnelle
ils se disent : "Tu vas t'en
rendre compte quand tu te fais
droguer, puis tu vas
le savoir."
Ce n'est pas vrai.
de bonnes raisons de croire
qu'elle a été droguée à son
insu, lors d'une soiréetes
où elle n'aurait consommé
que quelques verres.
Deux nageuses de l'équipe
à sa rescousse à l'extérieur
du bar où elle t.
- Je ne e suis tombée
inconsciente, mais à un de ces
moments, je suis tombée
inconsciente, puis elles ont dû
l en me... oui,
en me traînant et tout.
- D'autres athlètes auraient
possiblement vécu
traitement que Mary-Sophie
Harvey durant la même soirée.(c)
Entre-temps, Natation Canada
revoit la sécurité des ses
athlètes et lance une enquête.
NATHAN WHITE, Natation Canada- .
- À son retour au Québec,
Mary-Sophie Harvey déplore
et le chemin très ardu
pour d'obtenir de l'aide.
- À 9 heures le soir,
je suis tombée sur le répondeur,
puis malheureusement,
j'ai juste eu des nouvellesdeux.
MARIE-SOLEIL DESROSIERS,
- Mais je dirais que oui,
il y a quand même certainesresst
toutes connues? Est-ce qu'elles
sont méconnues? Peut-être.
qu'il n'est pas simple
pour les victimes
de s'y retrouver.
ELISABETH VIENS BROUILLARD, Féd.
- On leur dit d'aller voir
la police, d'aller aux hôpitauxt
sur des boîtes vocales,
bien, il reste quand même
sont un peu laissées à elles-
mêmes dans tout ça, puis c'est
ça qui est vraiment triste,
parce que ça prend
un accompagnement, après ça.
qu'il n'est pas simple pour
les victimes de s'y retrouve
Le manque de main-d'oeuvre
et la période des vacances
y jouent pour beau
qui espère que tous les acteurs
du milieu mettront leurs efforts
en commun pour contrer ce fl Ic,
Radio-Canada, Mon